after just one week it Dogtown that why
not - papa was rescued from microwaves
property are already taking all first
steps toward rehabilitation what custom
to an environment where violence neglect
not to come now they must learn to
socialize with people and other dogs
if these couples are ever to be adopted
dog - I was transformed every last baby
hey you little man right now we're
really assessing their behavior and and
getting to know them very a team of five
full-time caregivers carefully
introduces the dogs to a life with new
routines and boundaries Cupid are you
ready fit good boy
it appears to the stab that most have
never walked on a leash been grouped
or even experienced affection good boy
to work with dogs who potentially are
dog aggressive can be quite challenging
tiny dogs are conditioned to attack
other dogs so the danger of a fight
always looms the team never allows the
dogs to cross paths especially when
moving from outside pens to inside
kennels
come on little red the caregivers come
to know each one
their priority to enrich the dog's lives
and getting the possible toys play even
music important parts of their daily
routine as these pitbulls
overcome their fighting past adoption
now becomes a real possibility for some
ultimately dog town wants each big truck
to pass the canine good citizen tests an
important tool for evaluating if they're
ready for adoption to pass the dogs must
prove they're capable of following
commands are safe with units and safe
with other dogs we have very strict
guidelines in order for us to adopt
these dogs out so we have a lot of work
to do the screening process for adoptive
homes will be rigorous the goal fine is
able to handle whatever issues might
remain I personally believe every one of
them is gonna find a great home or if
need be we will take care of them the
rest of their lives